so here's the scenario of the question
right well maybe I should take a step
back so far we've been going in this
direction okay you know where something
is so therefore on the basis of that
tell me how fast is going and tell me
how that is changing as well okay so now
we want to think about going in the
opposite direction hence integration
okay so let's get a scenario Johnny is
what's he doing he's on top of the
building this Johnny is on the edge of
the building and let's say let's he
doesn't know how tall this building is
he just found that tallest building he
could write and as he's looking over in
contemplating he's thinking I don't know
if you've ever seen people do this
before he takes a coin okay and he drops
it off the edge of the door okay now
let's pause this this scenario here
whatever Johnny ends up doing I'm just
interested in the quench okay just
interested in now here's what we know
well he's on top of the building okay
and or don't know how tall it is so this
is not a good place for us to start
right I don't know where I am
right but what I do know is if you just
just drop the coin assuming he doesn't
know actually throw it I do know how
it's accelerating okay because we talked
we talked about this very briefly the
one even if you're not a physics you
kind of person then one force were all
familiar really it's gravity okay so
I've got gravity pulling downwards okay
now to work with gravity a question will
tell you assume and now I only give you
one of two options okay who knows what
the gravitational constant is speed
which it accelerates on our planet we
give it 9.8 which of course is not exact
we give that as the actual force that's
being applied for gravity but sometimes
you know I guess they're just being nice
to us because this is so close to ten
sometimes I'll say 10 you can imagine as
you change your question as you work on
your question which one you pick kind of
makes a difference right so always go
with the one that they give you okay and
if they don't give you one then in
reading time you stick your hand up and
you're saying after raging at them for
not having given you the number you
saying what what value do you want us to
use okay if and this is very unusual but
you know just in case you're paranoid
it's like say you know how sometimes you
get external supervisors and they know
nothing about maths and for some reason
they can't work the phone and call up in
that staff room or we're in the library
and we can't answer the functions we can
have them what you would do is if
there's nothing here you would say
assuming gravity is and then you just
put in a value then then you work on it
okay right now assuming this is true
this corresponds to acceleration okay
it's about how the speed of this coin is
changing okay so I'm gonna say right off
the bat the a is equal to a being a
vector Direction matters okay so I need
to start talking about direction now
what would you what would be your
instinct what kind of direction do you
think I should apply this
downward let's lay my arrow is gonna be
right which would imply a minus sign
right - nice 0.8 now I think that's a
good thing to do I recommend it but I
just want to clue you in to the fact
that you don't have to you can actually
make acceleration of 9.8 one of the
things we're saying at the beginning of
motion was that this scenario right
sorry this scenario here okay it's
completely devoid of any equations we
make up the equations okay it's also
devoid of any axis or anything like that
so we get to decide where to put it so
in fact even before this we should be
saying something else which is less okay
and just like it rates of change you
want to introduce some variables and
that kind of thing there correspond to
the question okay now as you'll see
later on there are different ways to
choose where we should put things but
I'm gonna say let the top of the
building well that the origin rather be
the top of the building okay
so x equals zero is here be the top of
the building okay and X be now X of
course it is a function it's not just a
value so that's how I'm going to say X
of T to clarify this a function of time
they see it be the displacement
now some people will like to define down
as positive okay
now Nancy is very counterintuitive the
reason why it's so they can avoid the
negative okay sometimes it'll be useful
we'll work those examples through later
on but now I'm just going to stick with
down is negative because that's what
we're used to okay now before to get
from displacements of velocity to
acceleration the process we used was
differentiation differentiate with
respect to time okay
therefore in order to reverse that
process what you would expect is that we
would use integration right we're
integrating with respect to T so I would
say sorry I'm after velocity velocity is
going to be the integral of acceleration
with respect to time this is time to get
towards when I went to a union mass
there were very few numbers and you look
at things you like what kind of language
is it anyway you guys know what the
integral of minus 9.8 is right it's just
a number so what's it going to end up
that time with respect to time now
because it's indefinite I have to deal
with this constant okay now I'm going to
call it constant one you don't have to
buy generally motion equations in motion
questions you're going to have you're
going to integrate more than once going
further right so you can have more than
one constant I don't like having
seasoned D's in these hang around
because I start to forget what they are
whereas C 1 C 2 C 3 or whatever C's
always positive okay we're okay
now usually in questions like this uh
you know we're not dealing with motion
we've got X's and Y's and you get some
kind of information that allows you to
work out what the constant is
right so what kind of information would
we need here hmm we need to know nothing
something about how the velocity starts
or where it's up to at a certain point
right now I said Johnny got to the top
of Buddy and he dropped the coin off
okay so what is the starting velocity of
the coin it's not a zero I said you know
it doesn't throw it he just drops it
okay so at that split second when he's
actually released it it's not going
anywhere and then grab you starts to act
on it okay so therefore I would say but
okay you could say when T is zero V is
zero a faster way to say that is V of
zero so as V is also a function of time
right that's equal to zero therefore 0
is equal to minus none point minus 9.8
times zero plus my constant okay that's
kind of pleasant okay great so now I
know at any given time how fast it's
going
I'm also like to know where it is right
so to go from velocity to displacement
I'm going to integrate again patient 9.8
that's he is gonna go out and power and
then I have to divide by the power right
so what am I gonna get out of this -
good
okay then again another constant okay
now what this situ is depends on how
I've defined the question right since
I've said the origin is the top of the
building and Johnny starts at the top of
the building okay if in much the same
way as I did here I can say X of 0 is
also 0 it begins at the origin okay he
won't always as you see in the next
couple of examples but this is what I've
defined in this question therefore zero
is equal to
okay so now you're like did I really
have to go through all of that when
there was such a simple result what
you'll find is very very commonly you're
going to be your initial conditions will
be you start the origin in you're not
moving sometimes they'll say the
particle the object the car is initially
at rest so that gives you these kinds of
very simple constants okay so therefore
X is equal to okay great
now what's Johnny interested in well he
watches his coin and he wonder this
because it's it's very small and he
loses track and very quickly he wonders
where it will be after five seconds and
how fast it'll be okay so now that I've
done all of this integration work all I
need to do is take T equals five and
it's substituted really straightforward
okay so all the hard work will be in
here right I can get velocity which
looks like it's going to be minus forty
nine yeah and I can get displacement
which is minus work this out before I
think it's a hundred and twelve point
five someone tell me if I get them yeah
22 I was close okay
now therefore I'm almost finished
because all of this is in terms of
vectors and it's not in terms of
language right I want to conclude okay
so just like the question begins I'd say
after five seconds
how do I describe his velocity well it's
going at 49 one of the unit's meters and
seconds right the coin 49 meters per
second now I prefer saying this in
positive terms and then actually say the
direction inwards
okay in a downward direction I think
that's a little bit better than saying
it's traveling at minus forty nine
meters per second um some people will
let go through but I feel like could I
say everything else in words why don't
we say just in words as well I mean the
reason why we have it right 49 is
because you don't get any more
information out of it okay after five
seconds it's traveling at that speed and
it has traveled or it is 120 R and a
half below the top of the building now I
think that's kind of even though it's
sort of optional to add this extra
detail in about saying how long yeah say
you know take me a long time to say
where it is I think that's helpful
because different people define x equals
zero as different places okay so you
don't want to say I don't when two point
five meters from hundred twenty point
five meters okay you want to actually
say where's your point of reference
because you can pick different ones
there any questions about
moving 400 meters tall if the various
hundred meters tall then it would have
after five seconds and after five
seconds it will be traveling at assuming
it's not an elastic kind of coin it's
traveling at 0 meters per second and it
will travel